it turns out those electric skateboards
could be even more dangerous than they
look
hackers have found a way to control them
remotely leaving a writer in the lurch
so boosted skateboard is a small
electric vehicle that's in the shape of
a longboard
they go about 22 miles per hour with a
range of five miles or so you control
the skateboard using this handheld
wireless controller here it's got a
little throttle wheel on it so you can
make it wheels go faster and slower
security researchers Richard Healy and
Mike Ryan can hack into the control of
Bluetooth and take over rich Oh actually
rides this everyday as his daily
commuting vehicle and we were curious as
to how secure it was we found it was
using bluetooth smart or ble and it also
turns out that they weren't using
encryption so we found out that you
could actually jam this guy and then we
reverse-engineer the protocol so we
could take over the skateboard the way
we hack it is first we interrupt the
connection between the user's handheld
controller and the skateboard and then
we immediately connect to the skateboard
from a laptop and we issue commands to
the skateboards to tell it what to do
the best thing you can do once you take
over the skateboard is to tell the
wheels go full-speed backwards in all
the cases where Mike and I have done
this except for one recording
specifically you know it's going to
happen right and you're already starting
to brace yourself someone actually tried
to deploy this exploit on unsuspecting
users the time between when we gem the
Bluetooth signal and when we replace it
with our own malicious signal
instructing the both to do many things
it's so short that you wouldn't have
time to think anything I mean you would
be on the ground before you the hackers
will present their findings at this
year's Def Con security conference the
purpose of this research wasn't to arm
people or put people at risk the really
issue is that people are already at risk
and there are a lot of vendors trying to
either ignore or hide that fact the
purpose of the research is to expose the
risk and then hopefully mitigating